what's up guys bang bang this week there
was a lot that happened in the Bitcoin
and crypto industry first up is Bitcoin
itself has had one of the fastest starts
to a year since 2013. the digital
currency is up about 40 percent and
there's many reasons as to why some of
the new investor interest is simply
because people are trying to front run
the federal reserve's potential pivot
back to lose monetary policy on top of
that over the last 75 days or so there
has been an addition of over 500 billion
dollars on the top 10 central banks
balance sheet and lastly there's some
investor interest coming from the debt
limit which was reached back in January
investors are worried about a potential
default and therefore they want to find
an asset that is outside of the U.S
financial system regardless of the
reason 40 percent in the beginning of
the year of appreciation to bitcoin's
price obviously signals that some new
investors are looking at the digital
asset now of course we have to look at
the underlying fundamentals those
fundamentals continue to look quite
strong I usually look at three different
things when evaluating bitcoin's Health
the first is code execution is the code
executing correctly is Bitcoin doing
what it was designed to do we can check
that box the second thing I usually look
at is the smaller wallet addresses on
chain and what we can see there from an
adoption standpoint is that any wallet
address with
0.01.1 or one Bitcoin those continue to
hit all-time highs this means that
people around the world or dollar cost
averaging into Bitcoin and they continue
to accumulate regardless of price
last but not least I look at hash rate
and what we can see is since 2017 hash
rate has exploded upwards even though
there was many major crisis events like
when China banned Bitcoin mining within
the country and over 65 percent of those
miners had to unplug their machines and
move elsewhere
still bitcoin's hash rate continues to
move upwards meaning that the asset and
the network is getting stronger more
decentralized and more secure but now if
we bring it to the most recent week what
we see is that there is a lot of
movement first crypto winter is still
here local Bitcoins one of the longest
standing crypto exchanges it allowed
people to get Bitcoin in their local
economy that company is shutting down
amid all the pressure from this long
bear Market on top of that Kraken
another crypto exchange they settled
with the SEC paid a 30 million dollar
fine and they're shutting down they're
staking as a service program that is
because the SEC is claiming that staking
is the offering of an unregistered
security the day after Kraken settled
the SEC came out and said any firm
offering staking as a service should
come into compliance with the SEC it
remains to be seen how other companies
in the industry will move forward
whether they will keep those Services
open or not but we do see that there is
a lot of regulatory pressure right now
we have seen over and over and over
again whether it is the SEC or other
organizations they want to have
oversight over this industry and they
are forcing various companies to come
into compliance with their rules and
their regulations so in summary Bitcoins
off to a hot start to the year the
fundamentals still continue to look
great we see some companies shutting
down because of the crypto winter and
regulation pressure continues to be
ratcheted up and companies are settling
or trying to figure out what they're
going to do with products I hope that
you enjoyed this update and I will see
everyone next week